Hello, hello, BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Today, it's our 9th episode!
Thank you for joining us!
BAU BAU BAU!
For those who are joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO.
And is hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start off your day on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag, hashtag, FWMCMORNING.
Okay?
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Ruffians, guess what?
Guess what?
There's been another Pero Sighting!
Where is he now?
It seems like a ruffian is re-appointed seeing him in...
Blueberry Farm?
I guess it seems like Pero wanted to get a taste of nature's day from the forest.
Right.
I would like to too.
Yeah, I'm a bit jealous to be honest.
Why didn't he invite us?
I want to eat fresh berries too!
Not very fair.
I guess Pero must like blueberries the best.
They are really yummy.
Moco-chan, what's your favorite?
Blueberries are good, but I think I like the blueberries that are sort of green.
But I had to choose.
It just makes sense, you know, the green blueberries.
The green berries.
But my favorite type of berries are raspberries.
Raspberries.
Raspberries?
They're good.
But blueberries are good.
Strawberries are good.
I like the blueberries and the strawberries.
They're good too.
Ruffians, what about you?
Yeah, the unraped ones.
The yellow berries.
The green ones.
But berries are really yummy.
I'm sorry about Pero.
That's not very nice of him to just help himself to it though.
You know, these ruffians, they work hard to grow them.
Harvest them.
Now Pero's just eating them all up.
Sorry.
If we don't stop him, he's gonna turn blue or something, right?
He'll just turn into a big blueberry himself.
Kinda delicious if I imagine him like that.
But it's a good thing that he stopped after taking our lunch.
I'm sorry that he took your lunch, though.
You can just eat him next.
It'll be okay.
Revenge!
But as soon as we find him, we'll teach him some manners, okay?
Ruffians, please let us know if you have any more Pero Sightings, okay?
Remember to use hashtag FWMCMORNING, okay?
Hopefully though, Pero... He'll be back at the backrooms, right?
We're gonna go looking for him, so...
He better be there.
He's just going for a snack maybe.
It's his lunch break, right?
BAU BAU!
This is something really important now, Ruffians, okay?
You need to listen up.
It's really important, so you're gonna listen closely, okay?
We haven't really had anything like this before.
And we're really sad and disappointed that it's come to this day.
But it's really important that this is said.
So we really wanted to take some time to speak to you heart to heart.
Not a misunderstanding.
Especially you, Fuwawa.
Go ahead.
Ruffians, I, Fuwawa Abyssgard, have an apology to make to you.
I apologize for my uncalled fit of anger.
You know, yesterday doing Donkey Kong Country.
You know, we're having lots of fun trying to get to the Minecraft Carnage level.
And you know, even after we're talking about how we're enjoying it and that we're feeling no pain and you know, it's like playing a game with a friend.
Yeah, you did.
But, but, but, I only snapped because it had set me up to die after Mococo-chan had died, you know?
As an excuse.
It was the furthest we had reached!
You understand, right?
Right?
I apologize.
Is that really an apology?
I apologize for calling Donkey Kong Country stupid even after it has provided us and countless ruffians many hours of fun and entertainment and precious memories.
Even though we're only 15% through the game.
Countless hours.
I'm sorry Donkey.
I'm sorry Diddy.
And most importantly...
I'm sorry, Candy.
Excuse me, I don't think that's good enough.
You didn't call them by their last name.
Donkey Kong!
Diddy Kong!
Candy Kong.
Is she part of the family?
She hopes to see.
She's a part of the family.
Candy, please let us see you more often next time, okay?
This is my apology.
From my heart to yours.
Do you accept it?
Ruffians.
Was that heartfelt enough?
Dogeza?
I'm a dog, but I don't need to dogeza.
No, it doesn't fit the crime.
It doesn't fit the crime.
If you can tell, I'm innocent.
I just happened to be in the photo.
You died, so... I don't know about that.
You played a part.
Was it heartfelt enough?
It's good she's atoned for the crimes.
Good apology.
Ruffians, you'll just have to dogeza for Fuwawa, okay?
Okay.
I did nothing wrong.
No dogeza, okay?
There might be something a bit more to... Ruffians.
There's been...
Another misunderstanding.
You know, we were getting a bit crazy doing Donkey Kong Country today.
Ruffians, you noticed, right?
Right.
Right?
Like, five minutes after we started, it was already getting crazy.
Just a bit.
We were laughing and screaming a lot.
Maybe a bit too much.
It wasn't getting out of hand, right?
I think it was getting out of hand.
We didn't turn into monkeys, right?
We're dogs!
Not monkeys!
Right?
Is this what you mean by putting the dog in the monkey?
Is that what we did yesterday?
We became the monkey?
Maybe that's what it is.
Maybe.
But we did talk about, you know, how when we were...
Actually... Actually... You know...
It wasn't even a full game.
It wasn't!
It wasn't a full game!
It was just a demo disc for a Crash Bandicoot game that came with the magazine.
It was just a trial!
Just a trial!
But we would scream and laugh so hard for it that we were told that we're not allowed to play it.
So I've never properly played a ba- a- Crash Bandicoot.
I can't say it!
Can you say it?
Crash Bandicoot game.
Yeah.
But I wonder though if the game is that fun and crazy just like that one level was.
It might not be good.
It could lead to destruction.
Maybe we should stay away from it but... It's more misunderstandings!
It's not good!
Not good!
Ruffians, what is this destruction?
What is this chaos?
Obviously, it's still too much of a morning for me, huh?
No misunderstandings understood.
Got it.
That's good.
No more misunderstandings.
Right, Moco-chan?
No.
There's more misunderstandings!
Unfortunately, there was most likely our biggest misunderstanding to date yesterday.
Yet again, yesterday, doing Donkey Kong Country.
But I guess it was a little bit after that.
It wasn't a very good day for us, huh?
Lots of misunderstandings, lots of apologies.
There was a Ruffian who asked if they could live in Moco-chan's belly button.
Ruffians, was that you?
Was that you?
Huh?
Ruffians!
It wasn't, was it?
No.
Right.
Well, well, well, to explain, you know... I guess, without thinking...
I started to think about how much we could rent it out for.
You know, and there was a ruffian that suggested $200 an hour.
And you know, I thought that was pretty reasonable.
How could you?
But in my excitement, you know, thinking that if we rent in Moco-chan's belly button like a share house, it would make a lot of ruffians smile, I forgot to think about my little sister's comfort, and maybe what she wanted, what would be best for her.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for getting carried away, Ruffians.
I-I don't think that covers it.
I'm sorry.
You know, the Ruffian smiles are important, and I do want to make a lot of Ruffians smile, but not at the cost of Moco-chan's smile too, right?
Right!
Unless, Moco-chan!
Would you be okay with sharing your belly button?
How dare you even ask?
Are you really apologizing and then asking that?
I don't know.
I never got an answer, so... You did.
When?
Yesterday!
I don't remember.
Maybe I'm too excited.
Good.
I saw you, Moco-chan.
I am not sharing my belly button!
Okay!
It is mine.
We're not renting out Moco-chan's belly button.
We're not doing a share house thing.
I'm not happy having it up big on the screen either!
Stop looking.
It's big.
Big belly button.
What do you mean by that?
Hard.
Well, the misunderstanding is cleared now, right?
Is it?
Right.
Is it though?
Yeah.
No!
Ruffians!
Don't look, okay?
Don't look!
Ah, Moco-chan.
Yeah, this is definitely dogeza.
Yeah.
It's okay.
The ruffians are gonna dogeza for me, right?
And then it'll be okay.
They'll dogeza for even just thinking about it.
But Moco-chan!
Moco-chan, you have something that you need to confess, right?
Yeah.
Why do you make it seem like we're equal now, huh?
Cause we are.
We are!
We're equal because we're twins, right?
That's not how it works.
Ruffians!
I feel like we've already talked about this a lot today.
But maybe the Ruffians don't understand.
So we'll explain it again.
Ruffians, you know who Pero is, right?
Right.
You haven't forgotten, right?
Just because Pero's kind of... a bit... missing.
Missing.
Yeah, but... Maybe!
Enough Pero.
I feel like that's a bit of an overstatement.
You know, we're going to the backwoods to find Pero on Thursday, right?
Right.
Yeah.
But you know with how mean and rude Pero can be, maybe there's some ruffians that are kind of like, why would FUWAMOCO want to go find him?
Right!
You know, he is our pet, and as owners, we are also responsible for him.
We have a responsibility.
And you know, I guess he has taught us a few new tricks in the past too.
But you know, when Pero's not being rude and saying bad things, he's actually pretty helpful.
He's not awful all the time.
He can have his good points.
You know, I'm sure a lot of Ruffians have noticed, but since debut, things have been pretty busy at the Abyssgard home team.
It's busy!
We've been doing our best to prep and practice and stream as much as we can to get used to all the new things in our world now.
Pero's been helping us quite a bit too.
He's missing now, but... You might be surprised.
He does kind of have a bit of a creative side.
Somehow.
In the roundness.
There's a side.
There's a side in the roundness.
Yeah.
You know, he helps us out with the graphics and thumbnails and sometimes even video editing too, you know.
Somehow he does it all with those little wings.
Yeah.
But we only have four paws between the both of us and they're only 24 hours a day, so...
We're really thankful.
But I can do those things too.
We could.
But you're just really slow.
But if Pero does it, then Moco-chan isn't as annoying.
I'm not annoying.
If it's me doing it, she always comes up with all these requests once I'm done.
You know, if it's Pero, then Moco-chan knows that she can't bark orders at him.
I don't bark orders.
Maybe bark orders as much.
But that's why we're really thankful to Pero.
And you know things have been getting busier and busier, so that's why we need to find him!
Yeah!
Soon!
ASAP!
Let's do our best to get him back, okay Ruffians?
Got it?
We're gonna find him.
In the back room.
I need your help.
Please help.
But I need a lot of help.
Today's Doggie of the Day is...
A cutie!
He really does look like a trucker.
A trucker dog of the day.
He's a working dog, you know?
Very busy.
I've been to here, I've been to there.
I've seen lots of things on this road.
Right?
Like that?
Seasoned.
Maybe like, I've helped lost puppies across the entire continent.
Making families.
Come together!
Look at the elbow.
The elbow actually has it.
That's the true sign of a pro there.
And a little jacket.
Very fashionable.
There's such a tiny, tiny doggy for the day.
Lots of attitude.
Professional.
I want to know his name though.
If he drives like a Kei-tora, then maybe Kei.
Actually, FUWAMOCO, we don't have a driver's license.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
Not louder, like a BAU BAU!
Or like a BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Like that.
Maybe.
Well, I would say, you know, he looks like the kind of dog that nothing bothers him, you know?
Whether he's out on a drive or a walk.
Yeah, he's a pro!
Professional!
But, you know, I kind of feel like, even though he really likes the seat of a truck, I think the thing that he loves most is being in your arms.
He wouldn't admit it though.
Yeah, but a bit cuddly.
A bit cuddly, yeah.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
And next for today, I went on a walk.
This is a cute one.
We have a cute orange cat!
I love the ripple in the center.
Look at the cheeks.
We got some round cheeks.
Very very regal.
This is a very good walk.
We went on a walk and we had some teppanyaki.
Saw some cute sights.
Yeah, a cat on top of a dessert cart.
Cats and desserts.
It's the perfect dessert.
That's like whipped cream on top of whipped cream.
Right?
Yeah, this dessert looks delicious.
Very delicious.
Is that a tiny little tail I see too?
I think so.
We hope you enjoyed the Lemon Tart!
The other dessert is for me.
This really looks like the perfect walk.
Fresh air, yummy food, and a cat for dessert.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
So cute!
Next for our Question of the Day, we have De-den!
Have FUWAMOCO ever worn a kimono?
What kind of costume would you guys like to wear in a new costume?
Thank you for adding color to my life!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Unfortunately, we never wore any kimono, but we have worn yukata before!
Yeah, we really want to wear kimono as well.
Right?
Yeah, when we were doing Guard Dog Training in Japan, I kind of had a bit of a habit where I like to look at used kimono sets and secondhand clothing apps.
It was really tempting, but just looking.
Just window shopping.
Yeah, window shopping is fun.
But you know, I think we definitely have a hard time putting them on.
Just putting the yukata on ourselves, it would take us like four hours.
It's very difficult on your own.
It's a bit of a process, but you know, they're so pretty.
But it's also very important to wear it properly.
Especially, you don't want it falling off, right?
No!
No, yeah.
We'd like to try wearing Japanese clothing in the future, but it'd also be really fun to learn how to make the fabrics too.
We'd like to try lots of different things.
Four hours each, four hours together.
Together.
Not that long.
Four hours together.
It's manageable.
I can help Moco-chan, Moco-chan can help me.
No malfunctions allowed.
We want to try lots of different things, but I think the Ruffians know that, right?
But Ruffians, we're always looking for more submissions for the Pero Sightings with all your day, your walks, and of course questions.
Please submit them with the hashtag FWMCMORNING.
Thank you, Ruffians!
Well, let's take a look at our next stream.
De-den!
We have more Super Chat Readings!
Thank you so much, Ruffians.
We're gonna be reading more of the Super Chats from our monetization celebration.
We're still going through it.
Thank you.
Please let us take the time to thank you.
It might take us a little while.
A little bit, but... You know, let's have lots of fun chit-chatting and being silly while we do stuff, okay?
We're really looking forward to it, so we hope that you'll be there with us.
Too many!
Not too many!
No, never, never, never.
We'll be very happy.
Yeah, but hopefully, you know, there won't be any more misunderstandings.
Hopefully.
Yeah.
Thank you, Ruffians!
Let's take another peek at our schedule.
It's an Extra Special Busy Week.
Lots of fun.
We're going to be celebrating our 500K Ruffians this week.
It's going to be a busy weekend, but also a lot of fun.
So we're going to be kicking off this celebration first with some chatting about our feelings and talking a bit more about what you mean to us.
But then we're going to continue it with a rare, unarchived Rock n' Rawr Party!
Yeah!
What could we be singing, huh, Ruffians?
Huh?
It's unarchived, so... At least this time we're going to try singing a lot of songs that...
Maybe we don't really know.
But you know, you might know them really well.
It's gonna be a very different type of Rock n' Rawr Party.
Get ready.
Get ready for it, okay?
Copyrighted songs, they're always copyrighted.
I'm excited but also nervous.
Really.
Please get ready, okay?
You might wanna maybe prepare something for your tummy.
You might start hurting really fast at the ears too.
Maybe some water.
But you're gonna sing with us too, right?
Right.
We need your help.
I mean, we don't need help.
No, why would we ever need help?
No, no, we're good.
Well, Ruffians, thank you so much for joining us today.
Thank you!
Next time's gonna be our 10th movie.
Already.
Already number 10.
Time flies.
Thank you!
Well, Ruffians, before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Viewers today!
Pump Ruffiu!
BAU BAU!
Percy!
Dante!
BAU BAU!
Spike!
Asagi!
BAU BAU!
Setsuna Konoe!
Mr. BAUBOY!
BAU BAU!
Anko!
And to every other ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!
BAU!